[Musik]
sie tanzen auf allen wellen der schweiz
und sie fallen auf irina und wasserbälle
[Musik]
es ist die geschichte eines paares das
dafür berühmt ist berühmt zu sein bei
dem mancher längst vergessen hat warum
die beiden denn so bekannt sind
jedes gedruckte foto den
bekanntheitsgrad des glamour paares
weiter an
so ist es fast unvermeidlich dass auch
die reporterin nun das ihre dazu bei
trägt dieses schillernde zeitphänomen
noch prominente zu machen
[Musik]
im winter verbringen die bellas ihre
zeit oft an ihrem zweitwohnsitz in der
nähe von lugano
die 140 quadratmeter große wohnung wurde
erst letzten sommer bezugsbereit für die
einrichtung war der hausherr zuständig
das ehepaar teilt sich den wohnbereich
bei den schlafzimmern trennen sich ihre
wege im reichte russin zeigt sich jahren
zur selbstdarstellung ein aktbild der
hausherrin beherrscht den raum
hierzu haben wollte dass sie eben
einfach musste der coach auf 14 8 wieder
stark das ist nicht der einzige grund
warum sie nicht hier schläft ich habe
diese freude einheit braucht wenn die
haus gefühl kann ich ja auch von trainer
aaron hunt mit einem steward sie schauen
sie schaurig böse haben okay du bist
jetzt sind wie diese verstehen ich bin
daher gute phrase es ist wenn ich das
künftig wird den sofort raus meint es
mit diesem tag will irgendwie fühle
hier im ehemaligen waren aus ober in
zürich entsteht das grösste casino der
schweiz
walter beller leitet die bauarbeiten des
33 millionen projektes der mann mit dem
roller baut ihr sein achtes casino
juni vollständig gewinnt die planke man
verkaufen als er spielt aus der
baustelle war für mich so ein mann muss
100 meter hin und her ein schwindel
die tags zuvor waren sie dritter sowie
ein gewerbe nasenbruch können so wie ich
kann ja nie wissen
november unbedingt tätig sie vor so
steht patrick personal daher als der hit
begleitete ich sehe halt bloß wo das
natürlich ein älterer herr sagt ich bin
ein älterer herr und yahoo in rom
sorgfältig will das video hier kann
großes weißes gold
so schob sie haben sich heute seit
jahren tragen jahre her dass medien
reagiert hat ist das anders
du hast ja schon direkt von riekofen
wasserstraßen danach ruhig aber gezielt
das sind menschen zu bedienen
der hauptwohnsitz der bellas wird von
außen ungerührt normal
die wohnung sei die höchstgelegene in
pfäffikon schweiz betont die
millionärsgattin mit hang zum exklusiven
[Musik]
auch hier ist die einrichtung der 250
quadratmeter großen wohnung sein werk
für die bilder an der wand stand sie
modell irena bella ist mehr als gut
gebettet doch gut scheint nicht gut
genug geld hat man nur in einem immer zu
wenig und was dem irina bella ist das
tochter eines diplomaten in moskau
aufgewachsen und hat dort
filmwissenschaft studiert doch der
studienabschluss verstaubte im schrank
schon im zarten alter von fünf jahren
eröffnete sie ihren vater wie ihre
zukunft einmal aussehen werde
walter weller ist hier im zürcher kreis
4 als sohn eines arbeiters aufgewachsen
er ist ein selfmade millionär und
verdient sein geld heute vor allem mit
liegenschaften
[Musik]
job macht dann kann ich vor 15 jahren
gefängnis herrscht keine helfer das
führungskräfte um bauen wohnen ein
anders trainiert ich sagen ich bin
manchmal die häuser branche gezeigt
netzgebieten eigenes wurde noch eine tür
offen ob kassierten die franken sanieren
definiert jeder monat mir erzählen sagt
ich spiele vor davor wie ich verlange
auch die herberner bevor walter beller
karriere auf dem bau machte träumte er
davon fußballer zu werden und spielte im
nachwuchs team des fc zürich
aus dem traum wurde nichts aber die
liebe zum zürcher war eines geblieben
beim europa league spiel gegen lazio rom
scheint sich das ehepaar nicht ganz
einig welches team gewinnen soll
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
das gibt was sich 1
a
das ist die folge
sonic werktags
euro
[Applaus]
es ist sogar mit lucrate d'eau grenou
assistent war derart gelinkt hat er
kommt zurück
[Musik]
irina bälle träumte als kind davon braut
zu werden und erfüllte sich diesen traum
drei mal in ihrem leben
ehemann nummer 2 brachte die russen in
die schweiz walter beller ist thema
nummer drei das paar hat keine
gemeinsamen kinder
trotzdem hat frau bella einen prall
gefüllten terminkalender
[Musik]
ihre geschäfte kann sie überall machen
auch in der bibliothek des zürcher
nobelhotels irina penner spekuliert mit
einem budget von rund 100000 franken an
der börse bewegen sich wie eine frau die
russin handelt mit hochriskanten
termingeschäften sogenannten derivaten
ein bisschen wenn es krieg irgendwo im
golf gibt und ich setze mich auf
steigende öl wegen und hoffe es geht
weiter diese kriegt noch mehr oder sie
ist doch schon so -77 es war schon von
einer sekunde - 58 prozent jetzt schon
das ist das grösste casino von ganze
welt etwas bescheidener als seine gattin
bauherr bälle nur das größte casino der
schweiz und der reporterin ist links im
raum bau alltag endgültig beim
distanzierten sie zu bleiben
spekulieren das ist okay wenn sie macht
das gut und sie spekuliert mit ihrem
geld hier hat die dose gebiet
damit kann ich machen was sie wollen und
das ist mal lustig waren haben sie hat
erstrahlt und weise was hochpolitisches
auf
heute liefen die geschäfte so lala und
irina bella braucht ablenkung
fast jeden tag gönnt sich die russen
entspannung in dieser art das kann sie
sich nur leisten weil sie einen mann mit
geld geheiratet hat das ist ein erfolg
im leben positiv es am anderes auf die
anderen nehmen und da war ich ziemlich
giftig wollte eine und man montag am
anfang wollte da nicht viel geld
ausgeben
er werde geschaut und den wird so und
ich muss kämpfen
und jetzt muss ich meinen bremsen sogar
weil er es so im gefilmtes alles beste
und schönste und fenster und ja
[Musik]
walter weller ist 23 jahre älter als
seine frau und weiß was für einen
stellenwert sein vermögen bei ihr habt
sage ich einfach wahrscheinlich schätzt
die meisten schätze der sicherheit dass
sie abgeschnitten als katharina ist sehr
groß dass die ich für sie eigentlich
auch nur dass es probleme deutlich die
probleme bewältigen
sie fühlt sich sicher und du musst mir
nicht erzählen dass irgendeine frau
sicherheit nicht jetzt will ich mal die
you waren jung ist oder so aber später
schätzen eigentlich alle frauen von mir
aus gesehen oder sicherheit oder gut mit
leuten vorbehalten sie zurück nach
lugano der mann mit geld und die frau
mit dem sinn dafür gehen shoppen auf
ihrer einkaufsliste
ein neuer pelzmantel
die russin hat zwar ihre schränke voll
davon aber sie will jede saison ein
neues exemplar irina bälle liebt es
aufzufallen egal was es kostet
ich war nicht wenn ich auf der preise da
brauche ich eine doppelte grappa danke
die pilze sind nicht nur teuer sondern
auch umstritten
das ist auch sonst gern belz hat er
natürlich ein feld und christoph wir das
auch in der die auswahl der lieder und
die kinder die vielleicht gelegten haben
so zieren sind doch bei mir zu hause
viel besser raum gehören außerdem war ob
dieser theorie verschlägt es auch der
reporterin schlicht die sprache
das war kein preis alles umsonst
dann ist mir alles klar wenn ich kein
preisträger hat also ich will zwischen 8
gezogen
musik schrieb dramolett hitzeschlacht am
von toronto zusammen bringen
wie vieles 80.000
aber ich brauche etwas war aber
sicherlich sehr warm alter sie so war
und leicht und fällt das genau was er
wollte
bitte ok erzähle bilder schiller co
ich möchte diese unternehmen wir beide
ok erledigt beide soll heißen den looks
für 98 und eine netzwerke für fast
19.000 franken
die rina bella kann ihr glück kaum
fassen
[Musik]
die neuen ärzte wird direkt ausgeführt
für den luchs mantel ist es im tessin
viel zu warm
[Musik]
von lugano nach zürich der erste ball
der saison steht auf dem programm
für den perfekten auftritt lässt sich
irina bella zwei stunden lang aufpeppen
doch der haussegen hängt schief das
ehepaar hatte streit nun weist die
russin nicht ob sie ihr mann ab und
[Musik]
endlich kommt die ersehnte nachricht ein
bisschen russisch für steht kann man die
am ende wird verstehen
er hat nicht eine kuh genannt auch rossi
schon das finde ich nicht mehr so
besonderes aber es okay ich lasse mich
jetzt kommen du musst nicht neben macht
und alle wissen sondern ganze noch so
[Musik]
ein luxusproblem für dieses auto findet
man wohl nicht so leicht ein plätzchen
egal die reporterin interessiert mehr
warum die zurechtgemachte dame sowie
nicht begeisterung erntete das ehepaar
übernachtet im hotel baur au lac in
welch und später auch der ball
stattfindet
in ihrer suite nähern sich die zwei
streithähne wieder an
wir sind 100 jahre zusammen das muss man
auch nicht vergessen
diese sechs im jahr zusammen und zwar
tag für tag sogar auch die
geschäftsreisen
ja sie will einfach nicht mehr welches
wäre nicht rot beiliegen
während sich irina bälle in ihre suite
umzieht sind die meisten ballgäste
bereits eingetroffen
aber ein trainer so ist es vielleicht
doch eine zu machen weil das ist
wirklich schwer jetzt und unterhose und
nach augen auf und rennt dann musst du
eine zunächst nahezu ja so schön ist sie
schon sprachlich wird sagen natürlich
[Musik]
es folgt der große auftritt und er
findet wie es sich gehört erst statt
nachdem die meisten gäste bereits
anwesend sind
da muss
[Musik]
irina und walter beller sind gastgeber
am eigenen tisch für diese ballnacht
lässt der millionär eine fünfstellige
summe springen diese kommt im zürcher
kinderspital zugute
die geladenen gäste der bellas kommen
größtenteils aus russland
der streit ist längst vergessen
ist im ganzen frei
[Musik]
weißt du eine beziehung wo keine
spannung ist ja ab und zu er ist
langweilig und gestorben
es muss auf und ab geben welche gerade
lassen als der westen
[Musik]
trotz der spannungen hält die beziehung
seit 16 jahren
damals lernten sich die beiden auf einem
ball wie diesen kennen
[Musik]
du musst wandern sie ab ohne
und so inszenieren sich irina und walter
beller weiter schrill aber sicher nie
langweilig
[Musik]
die
[Applaus]
arbeitsplatz